I still text her every day because in a
way I feel like
she's still here
I'm gonna talk about
he was my best friend definitely the
whole way through but more so as I got
older yeah my dream was for him to see
me graduate high school because freshman
year of high school he got super sick
and we didn't know if he was going to
make it he was a very like
not strange but like animated texter and
he refused to use an actual punctuation
so it's like the exclamation point
question mark Emoji the like big red one
yeah so he's like how goes it Panther
because I was going to Chapman and
they're the Chapman Panthers where are
you prowling lately paw Emoji
exclamation point emoji honey we are so
proud of your accomplishments and
graduation I love you very much and I'm
so proud to have you as my granddaughter
you are so amazing to us and loved love
you so very much which I actually have
tattooed on me so and I said oh thank
you so much I love and miss you lots the
next day May 16th 2020 the day of his
passing he said hi my great my dream
granddaughter are you watching the Obama
ceremony for 20 20 years this evening
bummer we can't celebrate you in person
but it's important to follow all Health
protocols love you heart emoji and then
I was like doing my own thing that day
with my dad I was like on a hike or
something and I just like was kind of
irritable that day so all I said was I
don't know yet but thank you love you
too
um and then a few hours later he said
ceremony is on Grammy and I are so proud
of our favorite 2020 graduate princess
and I just said thank you
thank you um he would text me constantly
and looking back on it now I wish I'd
really responded more but as an 18 year
old when your Grandpa wants to see you
every single day you don't necessarily
like want to see him that much even
though you love him you know no I'm glad
it was a a good thing to end on and not
anything bitter but I wish I definitely
had been more expressive I look back at
them all the time I'm a very nostalgic
person so it's comforting yeah I feel
like he's here
I'm here to talk about my best friend in
China we met in junior high we were both
skipping class together
John and I always texted we're pretty
ratchet and there was this thing that
China always does she could be in the
most horrific situation and she could
look the most not cute
um but she would always say I'm still
cute though I still text China so I'm
gonna have to scroll all the way up
oh
um she said oh my gosh how old are you
now and they said 31 got in willed and
she said yeah damn we are but we're
still cute though
and
um the following text I texted was hey
girl and that was the morning that we
found her and she was murdered
so yeah
so this is the first time I'm ever
talking about it just because
um I mean we watch it on TV we watch it
in the news and we just never really
um
see it happening to your own people
leading up to that and just seeing her
so cute though like I know it's a little
horrible to say but even though she was
married I murdered she's probably like
I'm still cute though like I don't know
I try to find Uber in like this grief
process because that's the only way I
can get through it
I still text her every day
in a way it's like
um it's therapy I have like the oldest
phone but I don't want to get rid of it
because I'm super scared that way oh
I'm super scared that I'm in a
um lose the text some of the text
messages I've downloaded it like twice
already but I'm still scared I don't
know I just
it's the only thing that can hold on
my name is Michaela pack
um I'm here to talk about my favorite
topic
um Brendan McGregor Brandon was my
boyfriend
um he was the other half of me my my
soul my heart my love my everything yeah
I could leave him anywhere and he could
talk to anyone and become their best
friend instantly he just had a
personality like if you knew Brendan you
loved Brendan I decided to go to Ireland
by myself and I could have easily asked
Brendan to take off work and join me and
you know I thought about it a lot too
and I for some reason I was so bent on
uh just going by myself and doing it by
myself I went to Ireland I came home and
I remember just getting so antsy off the
plane and I remember him texting me
being like Oh you know I've got a I've
got a glass of wine waiting for you the
shower's ready like whatever you need
just all you have to do is show up and
come over
and um so he spent the next few days
together Saturday we actually went to a
Yankee game and it was such a fun day
so everything happened on a Monday and
the last few messages I had with him
were just him describing how he was
feeling to me you know
um and it wasn't atypical Brendan to
have a stomach ache and that's what I
thought it was his whole family I was a
little worried because it had gone on
throughout the night I had fallen asleep
he had texted me you know he was
drinking water and he was doing okay so
I texted him in the morning when I woke
up I said look at you babe and um
you texted back he said didn't sleep a
wink
not a drop in me
I said uh I was nervous you'd say that
I'm so sorry my love
and you texted me he said I'm going to
urgent today
and I said
okay Baba I think that's best I'm so
sorry you feel this stinky
and um
he texted me
it's bad probably the worst I felt
the last text I sent him was what time
can you go
after that I was driving to work you
know and he had called me
and he never called you know it was
really early when I would go to work and
I picked up and you know he said oh
I'm sorry I meant to call my mom I said
oh that's fine like whatever
um how are you feeling and you know he
was just like oh I'm I'm sorry like I
meant to call my mom and I was like oh
that's fine and I I was I said you know
I love you and he said I love you too
and
you know I'm so thankful for that
mistake that he meant to call his mom
and accidentally called me because I got
to say I love you one last time I got a
call from his mom
and she had said you know
he's gone
I'll never forget the tone of voice or
the way she said it or the way it
sounded the poor woman and I love her to
death and I just you know how hard it
would have been to call me and tell me
that and I just I just remember calling
her you know telling her that she was
lying
and I was in bed and I just was
screaming and my sister came in and you
know
I think at that point just just the way
I was acting she knew
she knew I didn't have to really say
much I'm so thankful for the text
messages I don't think I'll ever delete
them you know it's nice just um
to look through because some of the
things he sends me I still have to read
when um you know I'm not feeling so good
or I'm you know I'm missing him
mm-hmm
[Music]
hey handling big feelings can be tough
but that doesn't mean you have to do it
on your own whether you have mental
health concerns or just having a hard
time navigating through life therapy can
give you the tools to guide your life in
a different way and that's why I'm here
to tell you about today's sponsor better
help with betterhelp online therapy is
more affordable and more accessible
which eliminates the stress and
difficulty of finding a therapist to
make things easier better help is online
and remote by filling out a few
questions betterhelp can match you to a
professional therapist in as little as
few days to sign up and get matched with
a therapist you can click the link in
the description or go to
betterhealth.com Jubilee media and get
10 off your first month of Better Health
and sometimes finding the right
therapist could be intimidating but with
better help you can easily switch to a
different therapist for free without any
stress so if you have big feelings and
don't know how to navigate them consider
online therapy with better help click
the link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com Jubilee media now let's
get back into the video
I have a voicemail from my mom my late
mom she was one of those mothers that
was your best friend honestly we spoke
every day on the phone
um texted back and forth all day long
text each other pictures anytime I saw
something that made me think of her
something that I thought was funny or
cool looking I'd send her a picture of
it I do want to sort of not talk about
her diagnosis even though she's no
longer here I still want to respect that
part of her privacy but um she was
disabled for most of my life and she had
chronic illnesses and the doctors told
her you know this is kind of it like you
can go home to die
when I heard that I went up there
immediately I stayed a month
you know I did all her um cooking and
cleaning and
bathed her and washed her hair curled
her hair and did her makeup
she passed away three days before
Mother's Day this year
it was a couple of days after she passed
away that I went to my voicemails and it
refreshed and I actually saw it
call Dad
love you bye
the day that she passed she was really
not coherent I said hey Mom it's me and
Cameron and Kieran
and she perked up Suddenly
and I said we love you so much
and she said
I love you too
it would have been her 74th birthday
yesterday
and I listened to it then and I went
shopping in a craft store because that
was something we loved doing together we
loved sewing and crafting together and
she fostered so much creativity in my
life and I I thank her so much for that
and I wish I could just send her a text
of you know something that I've created
and just send it to her hey Mom look
look what I did look what you inspired
me to do
yeah I wanted to share my own story like
I just feel like she was such like a
great person that like a lot of people
should know about her she was the kind
of lady that you would see like randomly
dancing you're like oh she's crazy but
she's leaving her life like that would
be her like we grew up a lot with my
aunt and my mom and well my dad so she
became like my second mom she was a
person that would mainly like call me
out and tell me like hey you know like
this is not right this is not you like I
would try to ignore what she would tell
me or like the advice she would give me
we're a little bit more apart than I
would have wanted
she was diagnosed with breast cancer so
they only gave her like a three-month um
spend life to live but Godly she stayed
with us three more years she um she sent
me a prayer the prayer said um there's
no silence that God doesn't understand
or sadness that he doesn't know about
and there's no love that he will ignore
in tears that he would not appreciate
and then um I just like hearted it and
then she told me she's like hey good
afternoon
um she told me in Spanish I'm
translating
I don't know why you've changed with the
attitude that you have with your grandma
your grandpa and with me I would really
like to know because from my part has
heard a lot to see how much you have
changed
look for words you were
you were such a happy girl
and positive oh always smiling
sorry I put my part there's something
that I did that hurt you with with my
heart I asked you to forgive me and all
I have left to say is to tell you that I
love you and I wish you the best always
and makeup is your life
that was the last text
it's been a while it's been
four years already and they can't get
over it
could send her a message
maybe just apologize and let her know
that there's nothing that she did wrong
it was just me being dumb that I love
her too
and that I want to see her the next day
when she left you can almost like see
her smiling and I've never seen somebody
like the way that she did so in a way
I'm kind of glad that she told me that
because I know that she herself she left
knowing that she did she tried her best
she did everything she could to like
mend all those mistakes we were there we
told her we loved her we sagged to her
we hugged her prayed over her
so I know she lives in peace I'm not
sure
oh a little bittersweet today actually
yeah but I'm excited to be here so my
father passed away about seven months
ago from pancreatic cancer I recently
just also lost my mom three years ago so
it's a full-on package they're both gone
I'm glad that he may be as strong as I
am today because that's the only reason
why I'm here talking to you and that's
the only reason why I am deciding to
carry on
um couldn't sleep last night had a
little insomnia went to bed a little bit
too early sorry my my dad is old old
people can't text I don't know what time
they don't believe in puncturization
perhaps three gummies and went to sleep
therefore afterwards and what you put in
them things the gummies that you gave me
to help you sleep
um it we're on my way to chemo honestly
I don't know what I don't know exactly
what he was trying to say to me so I
gave him um these sleepy time gummies
um like melatonic gummies there was a
lot of sleepless nights for him just
yelling out screeching out in pain so
whatever I could do to make him lay down
I was gonna do it
so I said those gummies are really
strong haha and okay was trying to call
you before chemo I hope it isn't too
rough on you this time I love you and
I'll check in on you a little later
and he said um after today one more
chemo session
oh that's great news I know you're happy
about that and he said a
a smile emoji
that was it and it's really
scary to know that you can have so much
hope and drive to get better and
it just not be in the stars for you that
it's just the end and
our family had to had to really really
um come to grips with that that was a
very very very hard day to hear that
news what I didn't enjoy seeing is him
thinking that his cancer was a
punishment for us maybe him coming you
know up short as a dad sometimes
emotionally I should say and I had to
tell them no that's not it your body is
just sick the one time I've really felt
seen from my dad is the last birthday I
got to spend with him and um
when it came to me and him and like his
ex and his exchanges of gifts for my
birthday it always kind of felt like he
was giving me things just to give it to
me you know it's your birthday here you
go but not like something that I
actually wanted or I talked about this
particular birthday he it was a whole
big old thing the way he presented it to
me it was a Sodastream
and what's crazy about that is you know
I never thought my dad saw me
[Music]
and I love soda water like I'm obsessed
my auntie his sister told me that he
went to Bed Bath Beyond with his aching
side you know limping
making sure that we got the right
SodaStream that we got you know the the
syrups for me and everything like
that is
not to say I'm not grateful for
everything he's done for me in life but
that is the first first time I have felt
seen
and I need it to be seen because he'd be
left here without seeing me
this pain would be so much deeper
and he saw me
that's all I could ever ask for and it's
a soda stream
and I haven't even used it yet I've used
it like twice
I want the original like CO2 tanks with
the original thing I don't want him to I
don't want to use it up I don't want him
to go away
so the little things like that mean so
much to me and the fact that he stopped
trying for one year to earn my love in
these big grandiose ways and just saw me
gave me the little things I will forever
hold on to that that's definitely what I
needed because I'm not gonna have him to
walk me down the aisle he's not gonna
see my first child
he's not both of them both of my parents
are not going to see a lot that I do now
so I'm just glad they could see me
before they come
grief is a really funny thing I think it
was Andrew Garfield that was in an
interview and he mentioned you know
grief is all the unexpressed love
and I believe that wholeheartedly I
think grief is just love I definitely
judge myself for not crying enough or
not being emotional enough but it's so
different for everyone and it comes in
such intense waves and it will never go
away but it becomes easier to live with
grief doesn't ever shrink it stays
the same size
for the rest of your life but your life
grows around it so if anyone's going
through that please I encourage
counseling grief counseling therapy
journaling faith
whatever you can tap into tap into it
because you are supposed to be here they
did not leave for you to leave too you
have to stay
I'm encouraging people to stay
I'm desperately trying hard to stay
without them
can I show you a picture of us please
she always thought she had to be in the
front but
it's that one
yeah so we got drunk that night